RESPONSE.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS TELLS US WHAT HE IS
HEARING FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
TONIGHT.
>> GOOD EVENING.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, MILITARY
STRIKE AGAINST SYRIA CERTAINLY
LOOKS LIKE LIKELY IN ALL SIDES
ARE RATTLING SABERS IN WAYS WE
HAVEN'T SEEN BEFORE.
A COUPLE BIG QUESTIONS REMAIN.
WAS IT ACTUALLY A CHEMICAL
ATTACK AND IS THERE A WAY TO
AVOID AIR STRIKES?
IN MILITARY STRIKE AGAINST SYRIA
IS ON A HOT BOIL AT THE
WAREHOUSE BUT THE PRESS
SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS THING
TODAY IT MAY NOT BE INEVITABLE.
SPEAK OUT THAT IS CERTAINLY ONE
OPTION BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S
THE ONLY OPTION.
>> IN A TWEET, PRESIDENT TRUMP
SUGGESTED A MISSILE STRIKE WAS
IMMINENT, TAUNTING RUSSIA.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING:
"RUSSIA VOWS TO SHOOT DOWN ANY
AND ALL MISSILES FIRED AT SYRIA.
GET READY RUSSIA, BECAUSE THEY
WILL BE COMING, NICE AND NEW AND
"SMART!" YOU SHOULDN'T BE
PARTNERS WITH A GAS KILLING
ANIMAL WHO KILLS HIS PEOPLE AND
ENJOYS IT!"
THE TWEET BROUGHT HOWLS OF
HYPOCRISY.
ISN'T THIS THE SAME PRESIDENT
WHO TRASHED PRESIDENT OBAMA FOR
TELEGRAPHING HIS MILITARY
INTENTIONS?
>> HE CERTAINLY HASN'T LAID OUT
THE TIMETABLE, WHICH WOULD BE
BROADCASTING HIS INTENTIONS.
OTHER CRITICS TOOK AIM AT THE